[Music]
welcome everyone one of the common
questions that I hear especially from
customers who are considering moving
their data to the cloud for the first
time is what about my security right so
security I think is one of the main
concerns that customers have when they
are thinking of moving their data to the
cloud I'm Shiva sheeesh product manager
for Google Cloud Storage I also have
with me my colleague rhythm who is also
from the product management team in
Google Cloud Storage we also have with
us our friends from Peter Chad and Chris
from the twitters public cloud team and
in this session we are going to address
just that question how do you secure and
protect your data in cloud with Google
Cloud storage or GCS so let's take a
look at the agenda we are going to cover
a range of different things today I will
begin by telling you all about GCS what
is Google Cloud Storage from a product
perspective then we are going to take a
look at what are all the cutting-edge
security primitives and capabilities
that you get by design and default when
you use Google Cloud Storage to save
your data then we will also take a look
at some of the recent features that we
have launched over the last year or so
and how our customers are using those
features then we are going to have some
exciting new announcements we are going
to have some brand new product
announcements for the first time in this
session today we are also going to have
a demo where we will take a look at how
is very easy for you to use some of the
security capabilities then we are going
to hear from our friends at Twitter who
talk about how they have architected
their security posture for all their
data in Google Cloud Storage and in the
end we'll end with a audience question
answer session sounds good so without
much further ado let's jump into what is
GCS so GCS or Google Cloud Storage is
Google clouds unified object storage or
blob storage offering so whether you
want to do
ái or m/l whether you want to do
analytics and maybe you want to run your
big query pipeline or your data Pro
pipeline whether you want to do
kubernetes orchestration or you want to
use anthos most likely you'd start with
GCS GCS is a place where you store your
data it really acts like a key which can
unlock the entire data platform which is
Google Cloud for you right and even if
you have not directly used GCS you may
have been directly used GCS because of
the fact that whether you use Gmail
attachments or YouTube or Google photos
or drive they're all empowered by the
underlying storage stack and the
architecture of the infrastructure
storage which is Google Cloud storage
right so what is Google Cloud Storage
then Google Cloud Storage offers an
unified API and consistent latencies
across all the different storage classes
for the various different use cases that
you may have the fact that we have
unified API and very consistent
latencies across all different storage
classes helps a great deal when you use
GCS for different use cases so with us
you don't have to use a different API if
you are talking to the coldest storage
tier or you don't have to think of oh
how do I architect a system for offline
latencies because for us every storage
class has online latencies consistent
sub-second latencies GCS is very
reliable GCS is very cost effective
across all different storage classes and
last but not the least and in this X in
this session we are going to touch upon
that in great deal
GCS has a whole bunch of really smart
inbuilt security capabilities so let's
take a brief moment to look at some of
the key features of GCS so I talked
about unified experience why unified
experience is great is whether you are
using GCS for analytics or machine
learning all you are using GCS for
backup or archival across the whole
range of different use cases with the
unified api's you do not have to
redo your code or you don't have to
react attacked your systems because GCS
has the same API across Oster all
storage classes right and it has the
same latencies another great feature
that GCS has is this strong consistency
GCS is a strongly consistent system we
are not eventually consistent right so
what that means is if you are using GCS
to store your data in a region and you
are writing to certain files in one
region now in a very different part of
the geography say in the exact opposite
place on the globe if you try to list
GCS
you are going to find the entire listing
is strongly consistent so this has
tremendous benefits in that say if we
didn't have strong consistency and
actually GCS is the only plan of scale
storage system with such strong
consistency so if you are not using GCS
most likely to solve an analytics
pipeline use case like this what you do
is you would have an object storage
which is your data lake but you also use
a key value database which you are using
for your metadata consistency but if you
use GCS you don't need to use any other
system GCS takes care of it
GCS is also greatly redundant redundant
depending on what is your use case you
can use storage classes which gives you
regional redundancy or a redundancy
within a country or you can even choose
with multi-regional redundancy which is
across an entire continent right and
lastly GCS is scalable to exabytes like
you don't have to worry about
scalability at all if you are dealing
with GCS so sometimes new customers
coming from one Prem they ask me I'm
going to bring like hundreds of
terabytes or petabytes is it going to
scale right so you don't have any such
worries with GCS in fact in GCS we have
single customers who have more than
exabytes of data right so depending on
what is your use case you are going to
use different storage classes or you are
going to use the different storage
classes in conjunction right now if your
use cases
content distribution if you if you are
streaming video or multimedia or you are
hosting website information or if you
have a business continuity disaster
recovery use case multi-regional is
great for you one thing to remember
multi-regional is multi-regional storage
glass has inbuilt smart caching and
smart routing inbuilt in the storage
class itself so you don't have to
necessarily use a CDN at all right if on
the other hand your workload is very
compute-intensive
so what you are trying to do is
basically do a lot of number crunching
you may be running an analytics job or
you may be doing genomic processing or
maybe just general compute if that's
what you want to do what you are looking
for is your storage and your compute to
be co-located right and that is where
regional storage classes are really
useful because you predictably know this
is exactly where my storage is you can
spin up your compute engine instances
right there now recently we also
launched a storage class in beta which
is called dual regional and rural
regional really marries the best of
multi regional and regional so dual
regional what dual regional is it is a
pair of two specific regions right so
you exactly know where your data is so
you can Co locate your compute so it's
great for analytics or ml or other
computer use cases but it also has the
benefits of multi-regional in that it is
geo distributed across two different
regions so it gives you the protection
for disaster recovery near line and cold
line are great if what you are looking
for is backup an archive and for those
of you who are really on top of your
game and you have read our blog post
this morning
what is cooler than cold we also
announced today an archive storage class
which is even colder than cold line but
the beauty of our coldest storage
architecture is at the same time we
support even that storage class with the
same API and the same consistent
sub-second latency right so across all
these different use cases we have a lot
of customers who use GCS in a very
versatile manner I touched it up on this
point initially when I started talking
about GCS but it is worth keeping in
mind
GCS the way most people use GCS they
don't think of GCS as a point storage
product you know like from the earlier
days of like on-prem enterprise storage
you my
be conditioned to thinking about storage
in a very particular way but GCS is very
versatile we see very often GCS being
used as a data Lake GCS is the first
place your data resides when you think
of doing analytics or machine learning
or whatever really you want to do so GCS
is your entry to the entire data
platform that is Google now let's start
talking about security right so why
security by design and default so at
Google we don't think about security as
an afterthought
we don't think security is something
which can be bolted on later so even as
we design our systems and design our
products from the ground up we design
security side by side so this has
reflection in various different
dimensions so Google has the largest
private network of any public cloud
provider out there we literally have
thousands of edge node locations and
hundreds of pop node locations across
the globe so chances are wherever you
are wherever you are writing data from
we have an edge or a pop right next to
you so what happens is your data packets
Entergy CSS or Google's private network
at the closest point of entry and leaves
Google's private network at the latest
point of exit right so this has
tremendous performance benefits because
you know it's really fast it's our
private network it has tremendous cost
benefits for you because you are not
paying much for network egress outside
of our networks right but most
importantly it has tremendous security
benefits as well so for those of you who
are really experienced with security you
know security and performance do not
always go together this is one place
where it does right so the fact that we
have such fabulous private networking
you can get benefits of performance and
you can get benefits of security so
consider this example say you are trying
to write your data or radio data from
your region to two different regions
region a and region B right so with any
other public cloud network what would
happen is your data
are going to flow through the public
Internet for most of the distance and
then just when you hit your specific
region that's when your data packets are
going to go through your cloud vendors
network with Google on the other hand
what happens is regardless of wherever
your data is stored your data will be
stored in a very faraway region but you
are within Google's pop at the nearest
point which is close to you so this
gives you absolutely minimum exposure of
your data packets on the private on the
public internet right so when we talk
about security or privacy one of the
most important aspects of that is
encryption when you think about your
data in cloud for example you think of
data at rest and data in flight now with
GCS you do not have to worry whether it
is your data at rest or data in flight
your data is always encrypted we do not
believe in this notion of you know like
default encryption as an option in the
UI we feel default and option are sort
of oxymoronic so all your data whether
in flight or in motion is always
encrypted we also have multiple layers
of encryption in our stack so that is
that goes with our concept of
defense-in-depth
right now one caveat I would like to
mention here is for multi cloud
interoperability especially s3
compatibility because s3 supports HTTP
endpoints for s3 computable API we also
support unencrypted modes of data
transfer but if you are using GCS
natively all your data is always
encrypted
now what about encryption key management
we have a range of choices for you if
you want to manage and host the
encryption keys by yourself
you could do that in which case we
wouldn't know what is the encryption key
you are using in that case you just
specify the encryption key to us it is
called cast customer specified in
different key right if you want us to
host the encryption key management
service for you but you want complete
control in managing the encryption key
we support customer managed encryption
key for you
there is also this other range of use
case where you want us to help you with
end-to-end encryption key management for
that we have Google managed encryption
which is everything is automatically for
you we completely take care of the fact
that we have sophisticated cutting-edge
encryption key management policies
implemented now auditing is another
important aspect in security because you
know this is how you do your regulatory
and compliance but auditing is also
fundamentally how you prove to yourself
and how you can keep track that your
security posture is really working the
way you intended it to be and again
depending on what is your use case we
have various choices for you if you use
multiple Google Cloud products and you
want to do auditing in a very uniform
way you can use our platform level cloud
or it logging if you are on the other
hand a very savvy and very heavy
GCS user and you want to find out a net
level detail about like how you are
using the service like what's your
latency is was the throughput loss of
other information you can use gee CSS
custom access and storage logs now you
may be a company who have your like own
threat intelligence and log monitoring
system and what you are looking for is
basically a programmatic way to consume
all our audit logs and channel them into
your system you can use tag driver
monitoring to programmatically consume
all our audit logs now with all these
audit logs you probably want to ensure
that you comply with certain third party
audits and regulations so we at Google
definitely help you with that we can
help support you with a bunch of third
party audits and regulations and this is
a continual pattern of investment from
our side that you see for example in the
last year or so we launched bucket lock
and with that when configured correctly
we can help you with FINRA SEC CFTC and
CFR regulations now another aspect of
designing systems where security is by
design and default is DLP is really
example there right so DLP is data loss
prevention so I'll tell you how our
customers commonly use this special
feature which is out there so say you
are a financial services Institute and
you have a data set which you want to
move to GCS you want to use GCS as a
data link so you want to run your
analytics pipeline on top but before you
run your analytic pipeline you want to
ensure that all the PII that you have in
your data you might have first name last
names email addresses you might have
social security numbers credit card
numbers so you want to insure before you
run all the analytics pipeline all the
data is redacted right it is
desensitized so for those of you who are
attending this session by our friends
from Scotia Bank you would see that
right now DLP has the single pane of
glass like literally one page few clicks
ability where you can specify an
end-to-end analytics pipeline with GCS
and you can completely eliminate all the
PII in your pipeline using DLP now DLP
can help you definitely with data
reduction and desensitization but even
if you the fundamental thing that you
want is to get a very good understanding
of how is your PII to visualize and
manage your PII you can use DLP for that
too so these are all great examples of
security built in for you by design and
default but at the same time from a
customer use case perspective and
requirement perspective also you need us
to build certain capabilities so I want
to briefly touch upon a few customer
focused security capabilities that we
launched recently in last year's next we
announced cloud kms in beta currently
cloud came a citizen G a cloud kms
allows you to have complete end-to-end
control for your encryption key
management in Chicago cloud summit we
launched bucket lock and what bucket
lock basically is it is basically warm
storage right so it is immutable storage
so if your use cases
I want to write some data and specify a
retention period during
which this data should be unmodifiable I
shouldn't be able to modify I shouldn't
be able to delete this data then bucket
lock is the right product for you right
VPC service controls so if your main
concern is data exfiltration right so
say if you are coming from on Prem or
you have your own private data centers
or private cloud and you want to ensure
you carry the same security posture as
you come to Google VPC is the right
product for you and you know this is
this is a testament to the fact that we
innovated where our customers had
requirements in a very short span of
time we have over 5,000 projects using
these features we have over 5 billion
operations we have tens of petabytes of
data which is already using these
features and we have over 100 petabytes
of data which is planned for migration
using these features right so this is a
continual pattern that you would see
where we had Google want to ensure that
we innovate exactly where you need us to
innovate where you have your
requirements right and to continue in
this vein
I would now like to invite my colleague
rashim who's got a bunch of exciting new
announcements for you enjoy Thank You
sugar sheesh hello everyone welcome
today we're going to announce 4 new
features related to GCS security so
let's get started the first feature that
we're announcing is V PC service
controls which is now in GA with V PC
service controls you can make your own
virtual private cloud within JCP so
customers that come from traditional
enterprise on-premise environments may
find it challenging sometimes to
re-architect their network perimeters
and public clouds and this is exactly
the problem that V PC service controls
is going to help you solve so with V PC
service controls you can very easily set
up a network perimeter or network
firewall keep certain resources within
that perimeter for example your GCS
instance or your bigquery instance allow
those resources to be able to talk with
each other and block access to resources
outside of the perimeter so in this
image here you can see that the green
represents
like the virtual private cloud whereas
the red represents services that don't
have access now with VPC service
controls you can also configure and
extend the firewall as you prefer you
can whitelist certain IP addresses as
well VPC service controls really gives
you a strong foundation to build your
own virtual private cloud and we hope
you get the feature a try next we'd like
to announce that bucket policy only is
now in beta bucket policy only makes the
process of managing permissions for
enterprise companies a lot easier so
with bucket policy only all you have to
do is set a bucket level I am policy and
then any object or data that you upload
to your bucket will adhere to the policy
that you set at the bucket level so if
you take a step back for a moment and
imagine what it's like to have thousands
of buckets with millions of objects in
them or even hundreds of millions of
objects with you know millions of object
apples and then it can become quite
apparent that managing object level
Ackles is sometimes hard and difficult
and with bucket policy only you no
longer have to do that you can just set
a bucket level I am policy and rest
assured knowing that everything in your
bucket adheres to those permissions so
with bucket policy only you get this
added benefit of preventing data
exposure accidental data exposure and
the reason why that is is because now
you no longer have to worry about both
object level
Eckles and I am permissions granting
access and you know accidentally over
exposing data that way additionally with
bucket policy only you can use this in
conjunction with another GCP feature
called domain restricted sharing and
that will help you achieve the use case
of keeping your data within your domain
now we've seen that over since we've
launched a beta over a million buckets
have already enabled bucket policy only
and we hope that you give this feature a
try as well next we'd like we'd like to
announce two new features that really
help our customers that are focused on
interoperability and multi cloud use
cases the first of this feature is
service account hmm
which will be in beta shortly now the
problem that we're trying to help solve
with service account H Mac is that
tying HTML controls to service accounts
is a lot better than tying H my
credentials to user accounts and if you
step back for a moment and imagine a use
case where or a scenario rather where
you've tied hmmm dentals to user
accounts it may become apparent that
when something happens to that user
account like the employee that is tied
to that user account leaves or the user
account becomes disabled for example you
may risk an outage or you may risk loss
to the data that those credentials
provided with service account H Mac you
can prevent this from happening by
instead tying your H my credentials to
service accounts now with this feature
also offers you the ability to
completely manage the lifecycle of H Mac
keys next we'd like to announce that V
force signature support is now in beta
as well so again this is for our multi
cloud users out there with re4 signature
support you can make very minimal
changes to your code base and access
multiple on object stores with v4
signing we support this for both hmmm
keys and Google RSA keys and we hope you
try out this as well now the features
that I just announced and the ones that
should be sheesh mentioned earlier on
are just a few of the features that
demonstrate our commitment to security
I'm also going to go ahead and demo some
of these features and show you how easy
it is to actually use these and put them
in action so for this demo let's imagine
that I'm a financial security
administrator and I've been tasked with
three things first I've been tasked with
keeping the data that I store within GCS
encrypted and as Shiva sheesh mentioned
everything in GCS is already encrypted
but if you wanted to manage encryption
you could do so with kms and we'll go
through a quick demo that shows you how
you do that very easily next let's say
that as this financial services security
administrator I've been told that hey
you know we need to simplify permissions
management and instead of using object
level Ackles we'll show you how you can
use bucket level iam policies through
bucket policy only to make that happen
lastly let's say that you have a
retention policy that wants you
keep your data secure or unmodifiable or
immutable for X number of years
well bucket lock will help you do that
for any amount of time that you set up
the retention policy and we'll go ahead
and we'll demo how easy it is to use
bucket lock as well to do this so let me
go ahead and switch over to the demo
here so as you can see the first thing
that we're going to demo is how you can
use kms or encryption keys and upload
and whatever data you upload to a GCS
bucket you can pass that key and then
it's very easy to do this entire
end-to-end process so we'll go ahead
we're in the cryptographic keys panel
over here will click create key right
and we'll just create a keyring let's
just name it something fun okay and then
we'll go ahead we'll choose a location
let's say we're choosing US Central one
I'm gonna well now that I've created the
keyring it's asking me to create a key
so I'll go ahead and own all create a
key as you can tell I'm pretty creative
in my key names it's the exact same
thing as the keyring except with a key
one so we'll click create here and now
that we've created this key we'll go
ahead and we'll use it to encrypt data
that we upload into GCS so now I've just
switched over to my browser panel here
so this is this is the view that you
would see if you were trying to manage
your buckets in GCS I already have one
existing bucket but let's go ahead and
create a bucket so um I'll create a
bucket I'll give it a name okay
we'll choose a regional location we'll
choose us central one as this regional
location and if you see the show
Advanced Settings over here it'll ask
you to choose a retention policy so
that's not that's the next demo but
it'll ask you for Krypton as well so you
can go ahead and you can choose customer
manage key over here and then you can
select the encryption key that you want
and this is the encryption key that I
want 0 for 0 1 so
go ahead and all granted access so now
that i've guaranted this bucket access
to that key i'll click create and now
that i have this bucket let's go ahead
and upload some data to that bucket so
we'll upload the csv file and once the
csv file is uploaded you can see that
for the encryption it says customer
manage key and that's the key that we
created that's the key that we passed so
with just a few clicks it's very easy to
take your KMS key and upload data into
GCS and encrypt it with that so as the
storage administrator for this financial
services company i can rest assured
knowing that ok this is very easy for me
to go ahead and do so
the next thing that i was tasked with
was i was tasked with trying to simplify
permissions management so let's take a
step back and imagine that you're you
know you have thousands of buckets with
millions of objects in them and you're
using object level Ackles to grant
access so we'll click this bucket that
i've already set up before the demo
called bucket with lots of apples and
when you open this bucket you'll see
that it has a bunch of objects now if
this was a real enterprise bucket I'm
sure it would have a lot more objects
than I have for this demo like Maui and
like millions but so there are these
bunch of objects and if we go ahead and
we click Edit permissions on these
objects you can see that each of these
objects have their own set of
permissions or ackles tied to them so
let's say that for this use case I
wanted to make sure that every object in
this bucket I always had owner access to
and my colleague Shiva sheesh always had
reader access to well one thing I could
do is I could go through and you know
confirm that this is true one by one so
I can click on the second object and it
seems like if this is true I've owner
access he has reader access looks good I
can click on the third one and I could
sit here and you know manually go
through these one by one and then if I
ever discover like here for example that
I've given him the incorrect permissions
like he has owner permissions but I
wanted him to have reader permissions I
could one thing I could do is I could go
ahead and change this but you know if I
was to change that it might take me a
really long time to go through other
objects as well and change it one by one
so I don't want this to happen
unfortunately I don't want to you know
sit here and go through and do that and
I want to make sure that any time I
upload data into the bucket
Shiva sheesh always has reader or viewer
access well bucket policy only helps you
do that it helps you set a bucket level
I am policy that means that you no
longer have to manage object Ackles at
scale so let's navigate over here to the
permissions tab and now that we're in
this permission step what you'll see is
that it says you can simplify access
control with bucket policy only great
this is exactly what we want to do we'll
click enable it'll give you some insight
here that you won't be using ackles
anymore which is awesome I'll click
enable and now that I've enabled this
let's go back into objects and as you
can see I can no longer edit the Akal
permissions on these objects one by one
so if I go back to permissions and I
want to give Shiva Shiva access to these
objects I can do so really easily I can
click here on add members and then I can
add him over here and I can select the
appropriate role that I want to grant
him in this case storage object viewer
and click Save
so now that I've done that if you take a
look at these objects over here
essentially what I've basically set up
is the ability for should wish to have
viewer access to these objects access
for him is not granted through ackles
anymore and I can rest assured making
sure that anytime some data is uploaded
to this bucket Shiva sheesh will always
have your access and I'll have their
appropriate permissions I want now this
is really useful again if you have
buckets with lots and lots and lots of
objects and you have lots of users and
you don't want to go through the the
object Apple green you'll arity overhead
it's also worth mentioning that you
don't have to take an existing bucket
and then turn on bucket policy only you
can do this from the start
by clicking create bucket and here in
the access control model you'll see that
you can either set permissions uniformly
at the bucket level through bucket
policy only or set object level and
bucket level permissions great
so as the storage administrator I've
accomplished my second task which is
simplifying permissions management now
the last thing that I've been tasked
with is keeping day
that I upload into GCS unmodifiable or
immutable for X number of years so you
can imagine that you've been handed a
retention policy that says hey upload
data into this GCS bucket but keep it
immutable for 10 years
GCS makes this really really easy to do
and we'll show you how so we'll click
create bucket here and I'll just name it
that I'll choose the regional storage
location that I've always been choosing
u.s. central 1 and if I go into show
advanced settings you'll see that
there's a retention policy over here
which is exactly what we want to do we
want to set a retention policy so I can
set this for 10 years which means that
every time I upload data into this
bucket I won't be able to change
anything about it for 10 years I won't
be able to modify it won't be able to
delete it but because I'm sure none of
you want to stay here until 2029 to
prove that this feature works I will
instead for purposes of this demo change
this to 30 seconds so we're going from
10 years to 30 seconds here but I think
you guys will get the point so
essentially if I click create on this
bucket what I've done is I've created a
bucket I've wear every time I upload
some data into it like the CSV file
after upload I won't be able to
overwrite or delete that file so if I
click delete here it'll say hey you
can't delete this object yet you won't
be able to do it until this retention
policy is over until you know the 30
seconds have passed by so you can
imagine that for a storage administrator
this is very easy to set up if someone
says hey we need to hold this data for
10 years 15 years whatever your security
policy says or whatever regulation
you're saying you know says you just
with a few clicks you can make that
happen
and after those after that time is up so
in this scenario after the 30 seconds
are up
or the 10 years are up you can go ahead
and do whatever you'd like to do with
the object so I'm assuming 30 seconds
are up so we'll click delete here and as
you can see after that retention time
period is over it's very easy to go
ahead and modify that object so in
conclusion that the
things that we just demoed you know
bucket policy only kms and also bucket
lock are just three of the many security
features that GCS provides everything is
meant to be very intuitive and easy to
use and we hope that this gives you a
sense of the level of commitment that we
have into keeping your data secure on
GCS with that I'd like to turn it over
to our friends from Twitter Chad and
Chris who will talk about how GCS is
being used at Twitter securely you can
switch over to that great Thank You Bri
some great thank you very much for the
warm welcome
get to our science wonderful all that
preparation to say hi I'm Chad Hodges
I'm Chris healer and we're from the
public cloud services team at Twitter
and we're here today to talk to you
about how Twitter uses Google cloud and
specifically how we're using some of the
features talked about earlier in the
slides to help improve our security and
meet our security objectives so just to
start off here hopefully some of you are
tweeting this but Twitter's purpose and
how we position ourselves is that we're
here to serve the public conversation
and we want people to stay informed
inform others and talk about what
matters in a way that helps society
progress for our part being part of the
platform organization there are some
quick facts I want to share with you
about Twitter if you didn't know 321
million monthly active users a peak of a
hundred and forty three thousand one
hundred and ninety nine tweets per
second we have a significant on-premises
footprint which is maybe a strange thing
to say at a cloud conference but Twitter
has hundreds of thousands of physical
machines like when you talk about the
companies that are doing what we're
doing at our scale it's a handful at
most but at the same time we're
migrating targeted workloads to Google
cloud that's the partly cloudy t-shirt
I'm actually wearing hopefully some of
you got a take advantage of the panel
yesterday about that
and when I say targeted and that might
imply small but we're actually moving
800 petabytes worth of Hadoop data to
GCS and that session was yesterday as I
mentioned and you know we're clearly
going to be hybrid we spend a lot of
time a lot of energy analyzing that
decision and if you're interested in
that it's not something for this session
but there's a great video of Derek Lian
from Google next in London last year you
can check that out and I would encourage
you to do so because a lot of the
methodologies we used a lot of things
that informed our decision or things you
should be looking at as well so for our
team which is the public cloud services
team we have some high-level pieces to
our mission and against the backdrop of
that massive migration and the
recognition that there are other teams
in addition to Hadoop who can get value
from the Google cloud how do we engage
with the other teams at Twitter and it's
really important to recognize that we
have to scale we can't be gatekeepers
there are a lot of smart capable and
inventive people at Twitter that can
come up with amazing ways to use the
cloud to take advantage of Google cloud
and we have to make sure that it's that
happens and that's done with his little
friction as possible and then second
because of our scale and because of our
history we sometimes need support or
change from Google in order to use their
offerings and to be born I'm delighted
with the offerings that have been
discussed here today they've made our
jobs a lot easier they've made me a lot
more comfortable with what we're doing
and ultimately our goals are to make
sure that our customers that's the
internal developers and users at Twitter
can leverage what Google offers in a way
that's secure reliable supportable and
repeatable and again like we need to be
able to do that without falling into the
trap of toil for those of you with the
sre background and part of this is that
we're weighing convenience versus
security so Twitter is a public platform
as you're all aware Twitter data is
unique right it's a public conversation
we make pieces of that available via
api's but we also have to make sure that
we're taking into account privacy and
data protection and we're adhering to
the trust that our users place in us if
developers violate our policy is we're
going to take appropriate action we also
in our role
have to make sure that we have access
controls and compliance and things don't
happen on accident and to do that we're
leveraging VPC service controls domain
restricted sharing and bucket policies
pardon me bucket policy only and they're
pieces of our security policy uh
obviously there are other things that we
do but this has greatly simplified the
approach it's made it a lot easier to be
comfortable that we're doing the right
thing and it's also made it so that
we're secure by default and a large part
of the Hadoop migration project is
making sure that we've done that and
we've developed several services we
touched on those yesterday the demigod
services and that play in that panel and
as we move other workloads the cloud
will continue to architect our
environment to make it easy to do the
right thing yeah as Chad mentioned we're
hyper focused on security and regardless
of intent misconfigured bucket is one of
the easiest ways to expose data and it's
something we audit for and something
that we strive to prevent and a key
piece of achieving that is using the
tools that Google provides
so we've leveraged both the VPC surface
controls and the domain restricted
sharing and provided feedback to Google
in the process to help achieve that and
so with the vbc service controls it
helped us establish a perimeter so that
we knew who exactly can access the data
that's in the storage buckets and then
domain restricted sharing we can say for
example if I have a big query data set
and somebody's going to attempt to share
that that they don't share it outside of
our domain so it helps put that control
on top of it and you know those help
increase our security posture and with
that will hand it back to Shuba sheesh
Thank You Chad and Chris I think this
was very instructive to understand how a
company like Twitter with so much PII
and so much really important information
uses GCS and at the same time ensures
that their data is secure so in
conclusion I would like to touch upon a
few themes that we have explored in this
session
first of all Google Cloud Storage is the
unified blob storage or object storage
platform in which you can store your
data to unlock the entire power of
Google Cloud as a data platform we have
planet-scale
scalability but at the same time it's a
very consistent unified and simple
system our customers use GCS for a range
of different use cases when you are
using GCS one of the biggest benefits
that you get is there is a lot of
security which is built in by design and
default so you do not have to think of
you know like building every single
security feature from scratch there's a
lot that we already take care of right
and then in addition in addition to
having very good default controls we
also expose a lot of customer controls
based on your use case where it makes
sense and in this session as you have
seen we have talked about some features
we have launched over the last year and
then you also saw some fresh features
today and some demos you would see this
continuing theme that our main focus
from the product team is to listen to
you our most important constituency the
customers and to innovate where it
really matters for you so this is no
surprise then that there's a lot of
large customers and enterprises who use
GCS to do a lot of amazing things with
their data at the same time ensure that
the data is fully secure so with that I
hope you guys continue to have an
amazing next and for those of you who
haven't tried GCSEs yet this would be a
good time to give GCS a try thank you
thank you everyone for attending
session
[Applause]
[Music]